what about you've been a little quiet is
it is it because I put the red flags by
you
got some I got rid of some I appreciate
it
what was the question again sorry how
has social media distorted people's
perceptions and expectations of what sex
and intimacy are supposed to be
um
well I feel like my personal opinion on
sex is that it's
an art form
and I feel like it's a very spiritual
experience and it's a very intimate and
personal experience between man and
woman and it's like
I feel like on social media
it's been portrayed to be something that
should just be expected or given away or
it's portrayed to be something that
it's just like it's nothing like to meet
a man and have sex with him right now is
just
so like it don't get me wrong it's okay
because that's a personal choice for you
as a woman but for me I just feel like
to let somebody into you on
such and who are you thinking about
intimate no no one no one but I just
feel like to let someone inside of your
body like people that for me people
don't really deep it like so do you
think social media has made it more
casual yes
way way way more casual like there was a
point when sex was only expected after
marriage now it's after a DM or two do
you know what it means that it's just to
me it's been downgraded so much and it's
lost its value and I think as
someone
I just feel like yeah sex has lost its
value a lot especially because of how
much sex has been portrayed through
music just people just in general you
know I mean like I don't know
I don't know okay what about you what
about you I don't know who you follow on
social media but I don't see any of that
stuff I've got goofy stuff on my
Instagram I don't see any expectations
of sexual whatsoevers because
you don't see the girls with their ass
picks oh what does that have to do with
sex though
no sex and sexuality well what is that
well that that signals sexual
availability to a guy that's like that's
like what a girl's doing she's like
she's signaling that I'm sexually
available to men and so that where does
that lead
but it's so it's so common now I don't
like
I don't associate with sex anymore
because the way like like Tia said like
the way
we view sex is like a spiritual like I'm
not looking at your physical when it I'm
not thinking about your physical when it
comes to sex when it comes to actual
making love I'm not thinking like I'm
I'm looking at them but do you think
that's like a woman's point of view
because I think guys it's more just like
a handshake
that's what I've heard what's the man's
point of view
let's just repeat the question is it is
sex a spiritual thing for you guys no
I think I think we enjoy the chase more
than the sex I don't I don't know it
sounds like you guys are trying to
trying to put too much on it man like
women don't treat sexual spiritual
things like women are so empowered sex
yeah but making love like actual
what was the last thing last time you
made love but basically I don't
making love is the movies when you grow
up you watch movies oh I'm making love
and relax you don't make love like I
don't
I mean yes no I was gonna say yeah if
you're a virgin on your wedding night
but if you're not a virgin on your
wedding night like what you
would you if it goes oh you know he was
he was being too gentle's but I wanted
to go I wanted and that's really what
you want right no that's a weird and
only fans guy on the show and he said
his number one requested
um like thing is is grape like grape
fantasy is for women that's his number
one request okay so I'm not like I know
that's an extreme but it just shows like
what women want no and any man you know
any man that's been been with women and
you will start discover that women like
certain things in controlled
environments like to get me and if they
become more comfortable with you you're
gonna discover some of these crazy
things they're like you know what I'm
saying I'm a bit of a free but it's
because a lot of times women do want to
fill in these scenarios where they can
get themselves out of it and they know
it's safe so when a woman wants you to
grab her throat or do all these things
where you think oh that's a bit whatever
it's because generally like she wants
that but she wants to have it in a
controlled environment where she can
also be like no actually you know what I
mean so yeah like um
um but do you think that social media
gives women unrealistic expectations
similar to what we just witnessed yes
every type of unrealisticated
expectation on us I think it's the media
too like like Disney type [ __ ] Disney
definitely
100 like I think law of marriage is
supposed to be boring
yeah like the thing I always hear about
is is happiness right I'm happy I'm not
happy but you know what rip RP the queen
RP Lizzy but one thing I'll take from
the queen passing away right no matter
what you think of her is the duty that
she did now so when you look at the rest
of the royal family they just do
whatever they want they don't want to
stick out and to do what she what she
went and did because in reality that's a
very boring existence it's not what it's
not it's not you picking the man you
want to marry picking the woman you want
to marry it's not you living your best
life no it's gonna be years and years of
Duty you're never gonna do any
interviews you're not gonna have a point
of view and it's gonna be like that and
the rest of them will be like f that and
I think
I saw it in social media a lot of modern
women they don't have duty anymore and
they don't have to think what the queen
had and that was like regardless of
what's going on I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick it out and I'm gonna go and do
this and when I look at my mom and my
dad my dad um
my dad I was Diplomat from the Cameron
Embassy and he's also back where company
Cameroon he's the Paramount ruler so
he's the chief of all Chiefs
um so we come to this country because of
my dad and like
for me like
like I don't know like when I just look
at uh
foreign
like a lot of African people that came
first generation or um there might have
been one person that came first and the
other person stayed over there my dad
was quite fortunate because of his job
he was back and forth back and forth the
things that I saw my mom have to do as a
strong woman uh it's not for things that
many women would want to do today being
separated for your husband but because
of her doing that thing now her children
were able to go on to become barristers
they're going to become business people
to go and become doctors but that's
because of one woman's
um sacrifice you know I'm trying to say
to you and do you so that's one of the
things that that I think that's missing
I would agree I would actually say that
Duty comes first before love when you're
actually serious about someone in that
respect I mean I was raised by my
grandparents and I saw that my entire
life my grandma was so beautiful to my
granddad even in sickness she was by his
deathbed looking after him every single
day and I think that love was developed
from that I think women from the 19th
50s 40s 30s would think we're so weak
today she's like she's like you left
because you weren't half happy my man
had a side side family across town yeah
she's like and I stuck it out
it's like I met it I met the other half
out of his funeral you know and it's
like I even talk about like my family
like my mom got pregnant when she was 17
by my dad and they ended up giving up
the kid for adoption but she stuck it
out with him and they ended up getting
married later and it's like a lot of
girls like
they don't have the like grit to stick
it out when they're not happy and when
[ __ ] goes south and
um I don't know I think it's it's sad
because the kids are the one often times
you have to suffer
um but I'm gonna as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible